So onald Trump has again, for the econd time
in wo weeks, gone to a sporting event in public
and just been brutally, brutally booed this
time, even more than last week.
It's been, uh, interesting to observe in a
few ways.
It's a story about the wenty twenty election
in a sense.
It's a story about Donald Trump's bubble that
he exists in.
And it's also a story about media propaganda,
which we'll get to a little bit later on in
the segment.
So let me catch you up.
Last week, onald Trump went to game ive of
the major league baseball world series.
He was booed.
There were chance of lock him up.
That broke out throughout the stadium.
Arguably, it's less surprising at a ashington
DC baseball game, even though baseball is
not a particularly left wing sport as as an
organization, ashington DC is quite left wing.
It's not shocking.
He'd get booed, although people do go from
more conservative irginia to the games.
But Trump was visibly shocked by the booing
that was taking place last week.
We played videos for you.
You can see Trump grimacing, you can see him
being popped out of the filter bubble that
he creates for himself at rallies and at the
white house with Brown nosing suck ups all
around him.
And then there was a media propaganda story
that came up following it because Fox news
cut out the booing from their reports about
Trump's visit and referred to it as quote
mixed reaction from the crowd.
So that was last week.
Low and behold, over this weekend, onald Trump
goes to a UFC event in ew York city at Madison
square garden.
UFC of course, is a mixed martial arts league.
And once again, the booing just absolutely
brutal.
Check it out.
[inaudible].
Here's another ne of Trump making his grand
entrance
[inaudible]
and maybe most brutally is the last ne.
[inaudible].
Okay, I
think you get it.
So once again, some references to this as
a mixed reaction.
And of course if you put wenty one thousand
people in a stadium, you're going to have
some of clowns.
But it's a very negative reaction overall
to onald Trump.
Now this is why this is so interesting.
The UFC, okay, Trump is friends with big Trump
supporter and UFC president Dana white white
spoke at the Republican national convention.
He's a big Trumpist.
ne would expect UFC to be more Donald Trump's
crowd.
This is not some stereotype than anyone who
likes fighting is a Trumpist, but different
sports have different crowds.
And to some degree, even in ew York city,
you would expect the somewhat friendlier to
Trump crowd to be there at a UFC event.
So this could be a signal about wenty twenty
it's definitely a signal about Donald Trump's
impeachment, which continues to grow in popularity.
But it's also a story about media propaganda
as Fox news insisting once again that people
just loved Trump showing up there.
Check it out.
No, it isn't pretty.
Also, UFC fights like these guys are fighting
to take it all the way down.
The president went to Madison square garden
last night, watch Jorge Masbeth all I take
on Nate Diaz.
The call was that the fight was actually called
after hree rounds because of the cut for Diaz,
but the president got a big reception.
You know, the media can say what they want
about it, but this is a crowd that loves their,
this is not a PC crowd right here.
This is a crowd that appreciates the brawler
style of a brawler president who was there
in ew York city, city to belly of the beast
to watch this fight or somebody half.
It's actually saying that they mostly heard
boos.
This has become so juvenile.
If you actually listen to the video and the
audio there clearly were, were a ton of tears,
so Pete hedged or Hajj bath or I could have
trouble saying his name, whatever his name
is.
He's correct in that this is not a PC crowd.
And yet they still were mostly disgusted by
onald Trump appearing there.
You definitely shouldn't trust the people
who even days ago edited out the booing at
the world series to tell you if there was
booing at the UFC.
The videos I think tell you everything you
need to know.
But what onald Trump really needs to be doing
is just go to a NASCAR race, go to a NASCAR
race in, you know, orth Carolina or eorgia
or something like that.
And if they boo him there, he's really in
trouble for wenty twenty.
Um, I don't know that onald Trump has any
interest in going to NASCAR, but that would
be my recommendation to him.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram at David Pakman show clips
of the show, pull questions behind the scenes
pictures, including of the main studio of
paths, layer of the entire thing.
And while you're there on your end,
the Graham apt follow me as well at David
dot.
Pacman, we will take a quick break and a lot
more coming up on this Monday though.
ortieth today